[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faudrait quand même sensibilisé les
pays du sud pour qu'ils prennent
conscience de l'importance de l'écologie
parce que franchement il suffit de
descendre de l'avion de louer une
voiture et de faire le tour d'une ville
d'un pays du sud pour se rendre compte à
quel point ils en ont besoin ce discours
ne vient pas de moi mais d'une personne
avec qui j'ai travaillé il ya quelques
mois nous étions en train de parler des
liens qui peuvent être tissés entre les
projets au nord et les projets au sud
comme on a tendance à les appeler je ne
vous cache pas que c'est un discours que
j'entends très souvent et qui
franchement eugène est d'ailleurs peu
importe le thème les pays du sud ont
besoin d'être aidés sensibiliser il ya
ce besoin de leur apporter un savoir
quelconque je ne doute pas que ce soit
sincère et je ne dis pas non plus que
les pays du sud ont une conscience
écologique irréprochable mais tout de
même je me pose des questions sur cette
envie d'aider c'est vrai que dès son
prochain est une belle valeur mais dans
certains cas c'est aide peut s'avérer
dérangeante
prenons le cas des relations entre
l'afrique et l'europe
lorsqu'on entend ce genre de discours
que je viens de citer
lorsqu'on regarde la télévision ou
lorsqu'on tombe sur une affiche
d'organisation qui vient en aide à
l'afrique ou tout simplement lorsqu'on
fait un tour sur les réseaux sociaux on
se rend bien compte que le regard que
les européens portent sur les africains
est quand même assez biaisé on a
l'habitude de voir ce genre de choses
alors je ne sais pas vous mais moi quand
je vois ça je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
penser à une situation similaire mais
cette fois dans un pays européen
alors imaginons celle week-end les
enfants scouts joue en plein air dans
les rues de louvain la neuve et moi qui
n'ai absolument aucun lien avec ses
enfants je les prends en photo au mieux
je me prends en photo avec eux et
ensuite je poste ses photos sur les
réseaux sociaux
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit tout à
fait légale et que ce soir je ne suis
pas sûr non plus que ce soit appréciée
par les parents de ces enfants ou même
admettons que je sois leur animatrice
il ne me viendrait pas à l'idée de les
prendre en photo et de publier ses
photos sur les réseaux sociaux sans
autorisation pourtant c'est ce qu'on
fait en afrique
alors oui les choses évoluent et
aujourd'hui on voit de moins en moins un
enfant qui meurt de faim avec un gros
ventre et des mouches en accessoire sur
la photo on voit un enfant plus ou moins
propres et avec un grand sourire
mais au delà de l'état dans lequel cet
enfant peut se trouver
avons nous déjà pensé à cet acte qui
semble si banal aujourd'hui dans quelle
dynamique sommes nous lorsque nous
agissons de cette manière
pourquoi dans l'esprit des européens de
la majorité des européens
il devient acceptable voire même
admirable de prendre en photo un enfant
de truies une fois en afrique alors
qu'il serait impensable voire même
punissable de le faire ici
dans la même logique dans quelle
dynamique sommes nous lorsque nous
pensons qu'il est nécessaire et légitime
de sensibiliser les pays d'afrique sur
leur manière de traiter les déchets
devient cette légitimité
lorsque je pense aux relations entre
l'afrique et l'europe
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser à
quelques faits marquants à l' esclavage
à la colonisation des relations qui ont
évolué et fort heureusement on n'est
plus à l'époque on se demandait si
l'homme noir avait une âme on devient
pupille et ses ressources pour le
civilisé mais on vient l'aider à se
développer
cette légitimité viendrait donc d'un
passé colonial qui n'est pas vraiment
passé puisque cette vision de l'afrique
continue à être véhiculée à travers les
médias à travers les discours à travers
des images et dans l'esprit de des
européens
cette vision persiste car elle est
nourrie continuellement le professeur
rachid bembe dit d'ailleurs que l'europe
à décoloniser sens auto décoloniser en
parlant de décolonisation nous apprenons
dans les manuels d'histoire que la
l'époque coloniale s'est terminée dans
les années 70 mais qu'en est-il de
l'imaginaire collectif des européens
vis-à-vis de l'afrique
mon travail me demande de faire des
allers retours entre l'afrique et
l'europe
je doit éveiller les consciences je dois
déconstruire les préjugés ou plutôt
mettre en évidence l'autre partie
l'autre réalité celle qui est délaissé
par le grand public et même par
l'enseignement est justement en
discutant avec des étudiants
afrodescendants avec qui je suis aussi
amené à travailler
j'entends des témoignages qui sont
révélateurs julien étudie en
communication master à l'université est
en cours son enseignant diffuse une des
publicités d'un peu partout dans le
monde
de différents pays du monde après avoir
montré des publicités venant de deux
d'italie venant d'espagne ou encore de
belgique
l'enseignant termine par une publicité
venant d'afrique l'afrique serait-elle
devenue un pays une publicité du
cameroun représenterait tels les 54 pays
d'afrique
charline quant à elle s'étonne de
n'avoir jamais entendu parler d'eux des
résistances coloniale si elle se limite
à ce qu'elle a appris en cours
les africains auraient accueilli les
colonisateurs à bras ouverts à aucun
moment on ne lui a parlé de samory touré
par exemple samory touré était à la tête
de l' empire wassoulou au 19e siècle un
empire qui s'étend sur l'ensemble de
2010 jusqu'en guinée actuelle c'est un
mât combattu l'armée coloniale française
pendant près de 25 ans l'historien
albert sabatier le décrit le décrivait
comme un homme possédant l'audace
l'énergie l'esprit de suite et de
prévision le professeur de charline
parler aussi de la place des femmes et
l'évolution des femmes dans l'histoire
de l'humanité il expliqué qu' avant le
20e siècle les femmes n'avaient jamais
eu accès à l'enseignement plutôt à
l'armée pardon à des fonctions comme
l'armée il oublié sans doute les minots
ces femmes qui ont intégré dès le xviie
siècle l'armée royale au dahomey actuel
bénin
un dernier exemple
roxane est une étudiante belge qui ne
s'est pas fort intéressé à l'histoire
coloniale elle s'est contentée
d'acquérir ce qu'elle a été ce qui lui a
été enseigné à l'école à l'école un
pardon et ce qu'elle garde de cette
période de sur la colonisation
c'est une période de richesse une
période de civilisation apporter à
l'afrique
je pourrais encore en citer d'autres
mais je vais m'arrêter là je ne vous
parle pas d'histoires anciennes qui
auraient besoin d'être réparés au
travers de l'enseignement je veux parler
d'actualité
je vous parle de ses conséquences
d'enseigner l'histoire en privilégiant
un point de vue enseigner la
colonisation comme une richesse une
civilisation apporter à un peuple oublié
de mentionner des personnages qui ont
contribué à notre humanité entretien à
mon sens une logique de supériorité
cette logique qui engendre aujourd'hui
des discours bien intentionné mais
paternaliste cette même logique dans
laquelle il devient facile de prendre en
photo un inconnu pour aller exposer sa
joie de vivre malgré sa misère en lui
ôtant toute dignité
au passage si les cols abordés la
colonisation telle qu'elle a été
pratiquée en incluant les récits des
anciens colonisés en condamnant cette
période sombre de l'histoire en clamant
haut et fort un plus jamais ça
si l aborder les conséquences qu'elle a
engendrée et qu'elle continue à
engendrer aujourd'hui peut-être que le
jeune qui aurait envie d'apporter sa
pierre à l'édifice pour faire évoluer
les choses iraient dénoncé auprès des
instances européennes
les mécanismes de domination qui
persistent plutôt que d'aller éteindre
une porte au fin fond des filets
au bénin hrw a sonné le monde
le remodeler c'est aussi repenser ses
relations c'est ses discours ses
enseignements longtemps troqué est
biaisé sert jouer autrement l'histoire
et les moments de l'histoire c'était
inclure d'autres récits dans une pensée
universelle universel je nous invite
aujourd'hui à déplacer notre regard à le
décentré pour entrevoir une autre façon
de faire et de penser des relations
entre l'afrique et l'europe pour
entrevoir une autre façon de parler de
l'autre avec l'autre une façon de
dialoguer merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]